if you're wanting to go beyond your
current skill set and you want to be
known as a visual artist
capable of delivering beautiful visuals
i can help hi i'm cameron i'm the
founder of stylecraft
and in this video i'm going to outline
how you can uplevel your skills
as a motion designer but more
importantly i'm going to show you how to
get there with a lot more ease
and it's all because of the easy process
and the framework i've developed behind
stylecraft
so what is it about your current skill
set that has you wanting more
and most importantly why haven't you
made the progress
you know you're capable of here's a fact
old habits stop people from getting what
they want more than
anything else they keep you stuck and it
happens on a very subconscious level
let's face it dealing with learning new
skills and
processes can be tough but worse are the
negative thoughts and doubts that creep
in
and if you've ever asked yourself am i
really capable of getting to a pro
level it's okay that's totally normal
to be honest a lot of successful motion
designers have had these very same
thoughts in fact so did i i remember
lying awake at night
wondering can i really create motion
design for guys like kyle cooper
and danny yount can i be good enough to
do that work
to make matters worse it seemed like
other people doubted me too
like my own friends my own family and if
you know how it feels to have someone
close to you question what's important
to you
well you know what it's like it's tough
it's really tough
so then i realized something i could let
this become my truth and have it stop me
from getting what i want
or i could tap into that energy and
the time i spend on worrying and channel
it
so it gets me closer to my goals because
worrying takes a lot of energy
it wears you out so the great news is
this
if you feel this way it's actually a
good
thing you've got all the strength you
need you just need to harness it and use
it in a better way
and nothing will make you feel better
than taking action towards making your
goal
a reality every year there are people
just like you who are successfully
learning to design
and animate and create at a very high
level
in fact there are more people today who
do this than ever before
with all the information the tools the
resources out there
it's never been easier remember old
habits aren't easy to change but with
what's available to us
right now is the absolute best time to
make this happen
especially if you're committed to
knowing how to create like a high level
pro motion designer
because more importantly that will open
up so many more doors
for you and think about having a
community of other motion designers who
run the same journey
as you all committed to creating high
level motion design
this is the opportunity we have today
and it's why i'm so passionate about
motion design
this is the reason why i created
stylecraft
so if you're a visual creator and you
aren't anywhere close to where you want
to be
or you're a mid-level motion designer
and you want to seriously up level your
resume
stylecraft can help you so let's take a
minute and talk about what's included in
stylecraft and how it will help
you become a better motion designer
easier and faster
stylecraft was specifically designed for
visual artists who want to focus on
making
your work look more beautiful and it's
structured to break this down
step by step and to show you what to
focus on to make
big strides quickly stylecraft's broken
down into over 70 lessons focus on the
principles and elements of motion design
in these lessons i walk you through high
level processes and workflows of motion
design so you know exactly
how to create beautiful motion design
without getting sidetracked by all
the usual frustrations in stylecraft
you're going to learn about texture and
color
contrast repetition line shape
timing symmetry movement direction
form atmosphere depth typography
alignment grid composition rule of
thirds
negative space and balance plus you're
going to learn how to go from idea to
execution with creative briefs
mood boards style frames animation and
finishing
stylecraft is in depth and it teaches
you the foundations
you need to know to create a beautiful
motion design
stylecraft is 12 weeks long and the
lessons are delivered to you every
single week
these lessons not only teach you the how
behind motion design but the also the
why not many programs teach you that but
stylecraft
does this course trains you to recognize
and understand
what works in motion design and what
doesn't and it pushes you
you'll also be fully supported within
our private community and it's not a
community built on a social media
platform
no it's a community platform built for
one purpose and that is to host a
community
there's no fluff it's all community
listen i want you to know this
the people who get the biggest benefit
from stylecraft are those that have a
strong desire to improve
and to continually put into practice
what they learn people like ryan fygard
who was a full-time photographer
with an interest in motion design and he
got serious
about studying motion design and he got
enough results that he is now a
full-time motion designer
or someone like dale brody who was
already an experienced full-time motion
designer
and questioned whether stylecraft would
teach him anything
after joining stylecraft dale found
himself pushed to his abilities
and he continues to reference the
lessons two years later
if you see yourself in any of these
stories i just shared and you want to
once and for all design and animate at a
high level
stylecraft is for you but before we go
any further let's also take an objective
look at starcraft
who won't do well with this course it's
not for anyone who just wants to
kind of check things out you can't kind
of be a true motion designer
getting these types of results takes a
commitment to succeed
would you want to fly with a pilot who
kind of knew how to fly or would you
rather have a pilot who's
committed to mastering the necessary
skills to fly
it sounds like silly example but it's a
perfect analogy
stylecraft is for people who are
committed to doing what it takes to push
their skill levels
up another notch if the intention and
the right attitude
isn't there this isn't the program for
you and it's best
not to join there's also bonuses within
stylecraft
bonuses like stock assets software
discounts and more
the amount of value and bonuses when
joining stylecraft is
huge i'm also including 100 satisfaction
guarantee
this program has worked for hundreds of
people and i know it will work for you
too
try stylecraft if it isn't everything
that i say it is
and you don't feel like i've delivered
ask for a refund within 14 days
and i will gladly do it by now you've
seen that stylecraft gets results and it
saves you time
but you do have alternatives so let's
take a look at them
what would it cost if you were to try
and learn this yourself you could go to
a traditional art school program and
spend six figures
or you could go to another online
program that may be cheaper but is the
content really that good
and worse what would it cost if you did
nothing at all if you just stayed stuck
where you are now
wanting to be better wanting to create
beautiful motion design
there is another way and when you add up
all the hours you'd spend trying to do
it alone
not to mention the frustration of not
getting where you want to be quickly
well you deserve to take the easiest
fastest route so you can finally
create at a high level and that way is
style craft
to make the progress you want in your
life you've got to break your old habits
the way that you're going to do this is
by investing in this program
i'll walk you through the entire process
step by step
so you too can create motion design like
a pro
if you follow what i show you you will
make progress
and that's why i guarantee so as you
look to make a decision
just know this if you're feeling
overwhelmed with your current skill set
and you want to quickly up level or if
you're struggling to understand what it
takes to become a high level motion
designer
this is totally normal for most of us
the biggest challenge is trying to
understand
why and figure out the how life is an
ongoing competition for your time
and your attention and it's a
competition you rarely win
but it doesn't have to be that way by
making your goals a priority and having
what you need to make them a reality
you can interrupt the pattern and get
where you want to go
ask yourself this what's important in
your life right now
what do you want to achieve in the
months ahead knowing how to create
professional looking
beautiful motion design will give you
exactly what you're after
a path to becoming a pro motion designer
how long have you wanted to accomplish
this and how many times has this goal
been pushed the back burner
you have the opportunity to do something
about that right now
today i would love for you to join me in
the style stylecraft
click the button you see on this page to
get started i cannot wait to help you
become
the motion designer you were meant to be